on today's show we take a deep dive into
a single call
from an extraordinary young woman who
met her husband
got married and tragically lost him all
in the space of a few years
on today's show she tells her story the
thing she's experiencing
and the things she hopes to do to make
meaning of his loss in his memory
stay tuned
[Applause]
yo yo this is john with the dr john
deloney show
i hope you're doing well thank you so
much for joining us
we're so glad you're here i almost just
said
because i was feeling like i was 11
again james made that joke earlier
wasn't funny but i think it was
hilarious and so now i'm going to make
it all the time
because i like bringing up old
commercials from middle school that have
absolutely no relevance here 20 years
later but
i think they're still funny hey listen
on today's show we're going to talk
about mental health relationships we're
talking about everything addiction all
of it
and if you want to be on the show i'd
love to have you i'd love to have you so
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form it goes to kelly
i'd love to have you on the show
we've got bajillions of people calling
in writing in from all over the world
and i love it i'm
so grateful that you are here all right
listen this for real happened last night
100
of what i'm saying is true it happened
exactly as i'm about to explain to you
and i thought oh gosh
i can't believe she said that so
[Music]
i was with my daughter and we were with
somebody who has a very
very large belly and
we were just going about our evening and
while we were out and i heard my
daughter behind me
you know they just say those things and
you go please tell me that this isn't
happening
it was happening and here's what my
daughter asked that person with a large
belly
hey why do you have a big tummy
to which i froze my heart stopped
beating and as i started to turn around
my daughter expounded on her question
she said
why do you have a big tummy is it
because you always eat all of your
dinner and you never poop
it was pretty awesome and i didn't hear
the
the answer because i quickly dug a hole
and i buried myself
so i wouldn't have to know what was
going on with my child and
i just was assuming that person would
take my child away and i would never see
them and i would think a
fair response and b the last thing i
ever heard was my daughter
trying to do the math on
the human body and coming up with a
plausible explanation in her heart and
mind
and the person who heard that heard that
question was responded really graceful
and was actually pretty funny about it
and we've had to have some conversations
about how bodies work how poop works
how um food work all of it
and how kindness works the thing about
kindness with a kid though is
she wasn't being unkind she was
genuinely curious
why are your legs long why is your tummy
humongous
i know it's because you eat all of your
dinner
and it just backs up there for a week
after week year after year
and ta-da so anyway i want you to know
we are educating the youth on how the
body works
and gotta love five-year-olds in
oh geez louise we just gotta stop
talking all right
so let's take our first call here let's
go to laura in denver colorado
laurel what's going on hey dr john how
are you
i am plugging along man trying to figure
out how to parent
a five-year-old how about you i'm doing
all right thanks
very cool all right so for the folks who
are listening
um i got word about you laura from a
facebook post
you put up um
some time ago and it mentioned us
it mentioned dave i mentioned several
folks here in our little ecosystem here
at ramsey solutions
and somebody forwarded it to me just to
say hey just wanted you to know
that this was out there and i thought
man i would love to talk to laura just
to let you tell your story um
so number one thanks for putting the
post up but tell folks what what's been
going on in your
life everything got dumped upside down
the last few months so
talk to us about what's been going on
sure so
um
so um oh
man i feel like a brick wall
my husband uh jordan
was a huge fan of yours and some days
when he'd listen to your new show i
would
mess with him because he'd put on his
noise-cancelling headphones and right
when he put him on i'd start talking to
him
and uh so he passed away three weeks ago
um today three weeks ago huh
how old was he 31.
hey hold on hold on can i just tell you
i'm so sorry that that happened
thank you um i hate that
you know being on the receiving end of
that i've heard you say it to
probably hundreds of people at this
point and uh
it means a lot and i appreciate it um
jordan uh was
an exemplary husband friend
co-worker uh peer
he was a even a really good stranger if
you met him
and uh but he struggled can i tell you
that's
that's the most i've never heard
somebody say that ever
and that may be the greatest compliment
i've ever heard somebody give yeah
that he was a great stranger wow laura
what a compliment
he was and you know
when he passed
the hard part of being with somebody who
can sometimes um you know they're
they are an addict they've had uh this
addiction in their past and what i've
learned since
jordan's passing is that you know
sometimes
when people succumb to this
yes there is free will and you juggle
with that what did i miss
what didn't they tell me how could i not
know and the conversations that i've had
with friends of ours recently is
imagine you're at the optometrist they
put the lenses up everything will
explore
that's your view when it happens
everything's upside down but the reason
why you didn't see it at the time is
because every little piece of
information the text messages that you
re-read
the conversations you have with friends
and family it's like the optometrist
dialing in that vision
so when you say how could i not see it
it's so clear it's so apparent
well that's because that wasn't the lens
you were looking through when it
occurred
so take it easy on yourself absolutely
so today so did jordan die of an
overdose
he did oh man tell me this story about
his last day or two
um
uh jordan and i um
i was in tucson with my maid of honor
visiting
he went back home to seattle to visit
family he's got a
incredible family up there but he used
to tell me
and this is not a knock on the city of
seattle or anybody listening who lives
there but
he hated it it reminded him of the past
decisions that you know he had made that
he would wanted
would have wanted to change about
himself and he battled
in and out of rehab with addiction for
10 years and when i met jordan he
um this past week
he had actually been clean and sober for
five years
and he came home that monday night
and i picked him up from the airport and
i could just you know you tell you can
tell when your loved one's
a little anxious and uh
you know looking back there are some
things that occurred that maybe
had i known him in that chapter of his
life
would have been red flags but
when you're with somebody you trust them
when they
when you ask if you're okay and they say
yeah i'm okay and
you know you take their word for it and
i came from a place where i just i never
wanted to question
his sobriety or his journey because i
knew how hard he was working
yeah the therapist you know once a month
for an hour
he was you know always listening to your
show
always doing all the things that he
thought he needed to do
to remain on track and on his journey i
think it's why he made an incredible
project manager he was
extremely organized and focused on his
sobriety
and uh it was very normal for jordan to
not fall asleep before me so i you know
went to sleep after i picked him up that
evening
probably about one o'clock in the
morning after we got home and uh
with jordan's anxiety it was normal for
him to shower in the evening
kind of calm down take a hot shower well
when i woke up that morning
uh about 6 20.
funny how the brain will never let you
forget certain things
um the shower was still running and i
knew something was wrong
oh honey and so
you know i got got into uh the bathroom
the doors were locked
and we've got a apartment with two ways
into the bathroom both were locked and
uh
looking back at that now you know maybe
he didn't want me to ever find out maybe
he just needed the privacy right
we never locked the doors um
but i remember prepping myself coming
into the bathroom after i got the door
uh the lock broken and saying be
prepared
and uh there's something in your brain
that
and you can probably speak better to
this than i can that kicks into high
gear
because you know it's about to get real
and
i found him in the closet and even
when i saw the
the empty hollowed-out bic pen in his
right hand
i thought oh my gosh jordan had a really
bad allergy attack
this saturday he was filmed in seattle
and he was allergic to so many things i
thought
whoa his throat was closing he was going
to try to trace himself or something
oh my word what if he called out for me
and i missed it
and it wasn't until later that morning
you know
after the appropriate parties had been
here that
there was drug paraphernalia um found
and even when i found him i still
didn't want to think that that's what it
was because he had been clean and sober
for five years
doing all the things you know i thought
he should be doing that we
talked about together and his past drug
use
don was something that he mentioned to
me a week
after we started dating it was not
something he
did it's not something he didn't want me
to know
um and i appreciated that as a partner
you know let me
if you want me to be here and know this
and support you let's go for it
but the thing that i have learned is you
know
i thought oh he must have just been
backed into a corner with all this
anxiety
the conversations we had had about him
always feeling anxious in his mind
but starting to feel anxious in his body
i had said let's up the visits with your
therapist
let's start walking at lunch do all
these things
and i don't know enough about
addiction to know you know for certain
his circumstances in that moment where
he decided that's what he was going to
do
but i do know that what i've learned
from talking to people
after this has happened is that
sometimes
when things are going really well you
know
you got married you got a great job
you've both survived
pandemic layoffs and craziness you're
planning a wedding in cabo
you're planning on chasing your wife's
dream
and uh moving to new zealand to support
her through
her chiropractic program sometimes
it's harder to say no in the good times
than it is
in the bad yeah because you build up
some pretty powerful walls for when the
bad stuff comes
and the good stuff is just it's
celebration right it's good
yep or there's not a good psychology for
things are awesome and i'm feeling
anxious
you know what i mean we we know how to
prepare ourselves for war when we're
being invaded we don't know how to
stay strong when there's peace time
right
so exactly tell me how you're
i mean you you experienced the worst of
the worst
right you um
you had the what will be a blessing in
time but
the greatest most difficult challenge
on earth is to have to show up to this
to the scene of a loved one right and be
the first person there to hold their
hand
and you there's a distinct feeling when
you know
right and it just washes over your body
um
what's the last three weeks been like
for you
uh you know
i'm naturally i'm a positive person it's
a
attribute that i have and it's sometimes
it's probably so positive to where it's
annoying right
and you try to
you try to hold on to that but
when you realize going through something
like this
sometimes you're just going to be in the
suck for a while
so can i just say this out loud laura
there is no positive here right now
yeah you may choose you may choose to
make meaning over time
but there's no positive here this sucks
you know i am i
i agree with you on that um you know as
as far as the meaning but
when you say there is no positive here
i don't know if i believe that john
because the things that have happened
yeah the things that have happened to me
and to other people since jordan passed
whether it's
a conversation with the restaurant owner
um you know that we kind of held his
dinner at for our friends and family to
gather
the positive in that situation is when
he found out what happened
in jordan's anxiety struggle
he cried and he told me he said you know
what i had no idea and i'm going through
the same thing
and i'm gonna get some help and i can't
look at that experience and not think
that wasn't positive yeah no that's good
on the back that's a beautiful thing on
the back end so let me let me rephrase
what i was saying here
um for folks who are
have a tendency towards um doom and
gloom
when things go sideways or when things
are positive
they tend to look everywhere they can
for doom and gloom in this situation
i tend to be a optimistic person like
you and so
what i often will do is i will use my
optimism as a blanket to cover over
just sitting and hurt that makes sense
oh yeah
and so that makes perfect sense that's
what i meant by saying there's not a
positive that the guy you loved passed
away
10 feet from you where you're sleeping
right now
will things come from this absolutely
because of the life he lived right
because of the life you've lived and
there will be meaning made on the back
end of this there will be
a lot of flowers that grow
in this soil no question about that that
story you just told about the guy the
restaurant what a gift man
and my that's the purpose of having you
on today is that i hope there are
hundreds of thousands of people that
hear this and say
i'm gonna go get help today i'm gonna
sit down with the person that i love
who's struggling and say
let's go get help together right so
that's why we're doing this absolutely
but that what that's what that was what
i was meaning about um
there's no positive in the person you
love passing away positive will come
from it for sure
um you know sorry go ahead no go ahead
go ahead
you know i think um when you say like
whatever the last three weeks been like
for you
uh i have just you learn
things about yourself that you maybe
were aware of before but just
you know you hadn't expanded on yet and
one of those things is
when my eyes open up in the morning i
get out of bed
and you know i have learned from myself
i can't speak to the grief or the shock
or the loss that anyone else is going
through
but when i get up my eyes are awake
and my eyes are open and my brain is on
get out of bed
and i had no idea that grease
birth existed and
you talk about wanting to be a positive
person when you feel those waves
wash over you sometimes
the second one hits you you know hours
later sometimes you feel like you're
washed up on the beach and you don't
know which way is up but
at some point i'm gonna relish in the
fact that
i made it through that one and i made it
through the next one and you'll make it
through all of them
um but it's a choice and
you know the same way that i would
encourage anybody in
jordan's situation um to get help
somebody in my situation don't be afraid
to talk about these things because the
first thing i thought
was i'm the keeper of my husband's
secret
he trusted me and very few people with
this struggle about him
and although he was smart organized
focused goal driven
and supportive he was also human
and you know i i thought to myself
how could i ever share this with people
that he didn't know
i don't want to sell him out but
addiction was not 100 of jordan's story
nor is it 100
of mine but it is a piece of it now and
if sharing this
could lessen the stigma or the loss and
the pain and the grief
of somebody who has suddenly lost
somebody who
was battling addiction
you're allowed to grieve as much as you
want how you want
if they were killed overseas if they
were in our armed forces
if they were a police officer if it was
just
somebody who is involved in a
hit-and-run accident
it doesn't lessen the pain because
of their battle yeah that took me a
while to really
to get through there is no comparison on
grief
ever right your grief is yours
and your parents grief will be theirs
and his friends grief will be
theirs and his family's grief will be
theirs
and the challenge moving forward is to
be really graceful with
everybody and that people will be
graceful with you right
as you grieve this and it will hit you
somewhere weird
years from now right and it will hit you
somewhere weird a couple of days from
now and you'll be dying laughing and
somebody will hit somebody else right so
it's just being graceful but everybody's
pain is pain and hurt is hurt and loss
is losses loss
is loss right and yeah trying to compare
it or say mine's worse or mine's more
noble or mindset
man loss is loss is lost
who's witnessing this with you grief
demands a witness
that people grieve together and i think
that's one of the great curses of our
time who's with you on this
journey you're on
you know
i am so fortunate um to be
surrounded by so many friends
and family members and even
acquaintances
past co-workers people i haven't heard
from in years have caught wind of this
and you know i'd like to think that
being there for people
what goes around comes around good or
bad and it pays interest
and i've had friends show up at my door
that
they flew in from nashville they flew in
from sacramento
i've got friends in over you know in
england who have said as soon as these
borders open
i'm coming for you and tell people what
that means
to have that community because this is
not something you developed after this
happened
this is years and years of you being a
person
of like you said investing in
friendships and in community
relationships
not if but when something goes sideways
and
tell people what that feels like to have
people just showing up at your door
not saying anything bringing some crummy
food and just sitting with you or saying
i'll be there
like walk people through the feeling of
that
it's an it's an interesting feeling and
i will do my best to try to describe it
when you do anything for the people that
you love
friends family strangers whoever
when i say jordan was a great stranger
a perfect stranger i think maybe
that was one of his best characteristics
and we have always said to each other
we have no idea what somebody else is
going through
to know that people caught wind of this
and dropped everything and just got on a
plane
or came over you know
nobody knows what to do right everybody
says tell me if you need anything
call me if you ever need anything truth
be told you have no idea what you need
because you're in the sick of it and
that'd probably steal him in some ways
but laura is not coming back laura you
for sure
are yeah
for sure the chances of you even
remembering this call
six months from now is pretty slim but
yeah you're for sure in the thick of it
yeah
but to have that love and that
outpouring around you um
not only for yourself but for your
spouse
it means a lot and uh it has taught me a
lot
about when other people i know in the
future may be experiencing
i hope that they never go through
anything like this but
other traumas and other difficult
situations
sometimes you might not know what to say
you don't want to call somebody when you
think they're having a good day
what if they start crying they're going
to cry anyway so just show up for them
yeah
so um if you
could could be up on a stage in front of
a thousand
couples dating married on the brink of
divorce
figuring out you know 20 years in and
they're figuring out they still like
each other
if you could stand up there and give one
one piece of advice of wisdom to to
married couples
not that you know everything right um
you've only been married
like what a few years and but
you're standing up there on the other
side of a mountain that
many people will never climb what would
you tell them
you still have time
that's that's really it i mean there's
you know you still have the one thing
that i can't buy or make more of
and you've still got that that is such
an incredible asset and resource
to have but it's also something that we
take for granted
and if you're willing to put the work in
with each other
and invest your time in your marriage
and your relationship
in whatever you're struggling with
that's the hard part i'm already done
you still have the opportunity
and i would give every last dime i ever
made in this lifetime
to have one more conversation
you've still got time that may be one of
the most profound
statements i've heard in several years
you've still got time
period but you don't know how much
that's right every second yeah
so this is an unfair question i'm going
to ask you
and you can just say i don't know you
idiot
um or you can just guess knowing that
we'll all be graceful for it with you
what's next for you like what does
tomorrow look like what's the next few
weeks look like for you what do you have
um circling around your heart and mind
today
knowing that it's going to change so
jordan and i were are both very big
baseball fans
and people have said to me what do you
need what do you need
tell me what you need
tell people when your fridge is full
because it'll just keep showing up
so that's one thing oh the western world
loves to eat
laura the thing that i that's next for
me
is um i started telling jordan's friends
and family
if you don't know what to do for me i'll
tell you this
come with me to a baseball game sit with
me at coors field here in denver
talk to me about jordan ask me questions
about jordan
or we can just sit there in silence have
a beer have a hot dog
and just watch a game and that closeness
that you could deal with somebody who
just
sits right next to you you don't even
have to say anything
that's priceless yeah
don't have to have in fact it's not only
do you not have to have the right things
to say
would you agree laura there is nothing
anybody can say
it's a matter of hey i'm gonna go get
another beer you want one right
absolutely you're you're spot on right
there and the thing is is that
sometimes the conversations that have
made me feel
so much better are the people who have
been
up front and have said to me laura there
are no words
i'm just gonna tell you how really
insert choice word uh messed up
this is and i'm not going to say it was
jordan's time
i'm not going to say at least you got x
amount of months
oh jesus nobody say that ever
gee nobody say that because to be honest
i moved back to denver from australia um
in 2019. i met jordan a few weeks later
one of the best things about my husband
is that when i shared with him early on
that
men in the past had called me a
commitment phobe or a flight risk
he grabbed my hand and said where are we
going
he was smooth dude that's a smooth line
right there i'll give him that one
you only knew that's a good lie
and to come back home to the us and to
be
with somebody marry them move in with
them
and to have lost them all in less than
two years
wow they're out there don't settle
and don't give up because if i can
experience that
i've just learned that if you're holding
on so tight to something you're afraid
to let go of you don't want to be alone
the lord or the universe isn't going to
put anything in full hands
because there's no room for it
i love that so um
number one i just want i want to thank
you for being brave and for giving me a
call
and for telling your story here and for
inspiring people to be
positive people finding beauty even when
it's a mess
for teaching people you're modeling
for people how to talk about really
heavy trauma and really heavy loss
and you man you gave me a few quotes
right
be a great stranger to people
and to remember you still have time
thank you so so much for sharing that
hey laura i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
this
um two things that i've seen um over the
last
i don't know decade of sitting with
folks in your exact situation
the the tendency
is to like you said start looking at
text messages and
voice messages and behaviors and things
and trying to re-pattern and recreate
the past i've never found somebody that
that brought them peace
and i've never found somebody that found
a dotted line that made them go oh okay
but the only thing i've ever seen people
find peace is
with how you're doing which is taking
crooked steps into the future
in an effort to honor this awesome
awesome guy
and the second thing is i want to
commend you for telling your story and i
hope you will continue to tell the story
and you mentioned something that i want
to make sure that you don't forget
you mentioned that you're the only one
that knows his secrets
and that there is a story to tell there
there's lives to be saved there there
are relationships to be mended there
but i also want you to remember that
you're the only one that knows your
secrets
and those are worthy of being told to
and
you're a brave strong brilliant woman
and my day is infinitely better my life
is better because you
took some time to tell your story and
i'm confident with 100 certainty that
the people listening to this
um have taken a moment to exhale
probably a breath they haven't exhaled
in years
and are grateful that you took that time
to be brave too
so thank you laura for telling your
story
thanks john i i really appreciate it and
um
if you're ever in denver your baseball
tickets on me
including june 20th for jordan's
celebration of life
i'm so grateful for that um when the
astros play i will be there
and they will probably cheat but they
will still win they will beat your
precious rockies right thank you so so
much laura
um to everybody listening i don't care
where you are
what you're working through what you're
struggling through you still have time
you're worth being well find somebody to
talk to find somebody to reach out to
find somebody that you love find
somebody that you don't know
that you want to get to know if your
relationships on life support you still
got time
you still got time all right so as we
wrap up today's show listen we're not
going to do any song lyrics today
we're not going to um roll this out with
a song i want you to stop the recording
right now
i don't want you to text somebody that
you love let them know that you love
them
let them know what you're thinking about
them and that y'all want to get together
soon thank you so much for joining us
this has been the dr john dolone's show